All right. Welcome to another interview guys. Whoo.
We got Cameron today. You know,
your least favorite character in a start-up series,
a top five character to start a series. Yeah. I mean, thanks for coming.
You were definitely the cheapest to get here, so thank you so much.
You're paying everyone else. All right. I don't pay.
All right. That's a good start.
First things first for people who know who watched the start-up series. Well,
first of all, if you don't watch it, you should watch it right now. Okay.
There we go. Now,
the thing about Cameron in startup series is that he's a very,
how do we say a romantic character? You know,
he's very passionate and stuff like that. So how are you in real life?
Cause like they only know you Cameron as a character, but they don't know you.
Well, they, they say life imitates art.
I think romantic is a nice term.
Desperate's probably a better term for the 3% of viewers who are women.
I am single, you know, um,
I think at the beginning,
I didn't really know what my character was going to be on the start-up series.
And then I just came to realize like my acting's not great, but I can be myself.
I think your acting is great unless that's just yourself.
I am a lovable dork in real life, right?
Like when I was struggling doing pushups, I was actually trying.
Push us that wasn't acting, that was reality.
Tell you to do like a ton. But cause we kept,
we kept like retaking the same thing. I was excited.
By the end of that, the, the heavy breaths. Those, those were real.
There's a little bit of reality. There's a little bit of a joke.
I think it's me to the extreme.
So, so are you a programmer or something else in the startup series you are
approved.
I've written hello world in a few different languages. Um, but no,
I am not a programmer. I'm a data scientist.
Okay. So you're a data scientist. Nice. Nice. So let's talk about career now.
Um, so as a data scientist, uh, first of all, uh.
Work, uh, graduated out of UC Berkeley. Um,
and then I worked for Tinder for a couple of years and now I am working on
unnamed, large tech company in the Bay. All sick.
Don't wonder what that is. No idea, dude. I don't know, man.
They call it like head pages.
Pages. Yeah.
Yeah. I can't think of what that wonder.
I wonder what it is, you know? So wait, so Tinder was your first job. Yeah,
that is crazy. Oh, interesting.
So you might know a lot about relationships or at least dating.
I'm one of those people who joined Tinder because I didn't know how to do
relationships. So I figured like maybe I've learned, so did you learn anything?
Oh yeah. I learned a lot. I went on how many dates when I,
my first year at Tinder, I went on one day. It was bad.
Well maybe you were just very selective, right? Yeah.
Yeah. It was right swiping constantly. Um,
you get a lot of matches though and no none, no, no.
I had to put in work to get matches, but yeah, the first year was, uh,
it was a rough fee and then eventually I started figuring out what to and
everything and like, you know,
I was going on dates one or two dates a week by like my second year at tender,
just cause I figured out what to do.
Oh wow. That's actually a lot. One or two days a week. Yeah.
I'm a first date machine. Second day. It's not so much, you know,
one and done kind of deal. Okay.
Can I ask you more questions about that later? Because I want some tips also.
Yeah. So you went to Berkeley and then wait,
what did you study such that you went to data science?
Like how do you even know about data science?
Good question. Um, so I was bioengineering at Berkeley. Um,
I was pre-med and then I took organic chemistry and realized I hated
it. So yeah.
You're supposed to be a doctor. Your parents thought you were going to be done.
Parents are both doctors. They want me to be a doctor, uh,
a little bit. They, they made me take the ONCAT when I got really, yeah,
they didn't make it. They didn't make me study. I did not do well on it,
but they made me take it. Cause they wanted me to change my mind.
They were hoping, you know, that the change in their heart of hearts yeah.
TV on capita was eight hours was so much fun, man. Oh God, I gotta do this more.
I got like Caribbean med school scores. Like what does that mean? So like,
MK,
you gotta get like 10 points above the average to get into like a good us med
school. I got four points above the average, which is like,
you can get into a Caribbean med school. This is where like people go,
if they don't get into any of us med schools, they go to the Caribbean,
hang out there for a few years. I did pre-med I graduated pre-med um,
but I knew at that point I didn't want to do do bio anymore. Um,
I want to do some mixture of like stats and psychology. Um,
so I applied to PhDs and game theory and I hadn't taken a single econ class in
my wife. And so I got rejected from every single PhD that I applied to.
And so then I, I panicked a bit,
I applied to 115 jobs out of undergrad. Um,
and then it was a mixture of like analytics, product management, um,
and then UX research. Um, and the analytics ones,
were they the only ones that really called me back cause I had the math
background for it. So then I went into, uh, analytics.
You were doing biomedical engineering. Yeah. And uh,
and there were a lot of math in that I guess.
Yeah. I mean, it's like a lot of engineering classes. I like, I like stats.
So I did a lot of stats classes on the side and everything,
but like the bio in itself was enough to handle any of the math that you do as a
data.
Yeah. That makes sense. Yeah.
Cause I was wondering like what that degree do they even like look at you
because I feel like they would filter it, but I guess not.
On my team, there's a lot of people who are like bio and physics PhDs.
Like when I read my data science teams,
there's like a lot of people who came from like a bio and an engineering
background actually there's more who do that than come from like a stats
background or a math background.
And then when you started your first shop at Tinder,
did you enjoy it or did you not like why'd you switch?
I liked it, but I was working out in Texas,
Texas is one of those places where like, if you have a family, it's nice.
It's a great place to have like golden retriever to kids, white picket fence.
Right. But like as a 22 year old, you can only eat so much barbecue.
And like I was putting on weight and I didn't really have any friends out there.
Um, cause I'd never lived out there. I'd always lived in California.
And so like, it just, it was boring.
Cause I tried to move back to the Bay and when I did, I was recruited.
You could get really huge houses there. Right. Yeah.
Great cheap. Yeah. Do you get a nice house? Like $200,000 or so.
I think we should all move to Texas before it rises up again. I.
Mean a lot of companies are going to Austin at this point.
Okay. Well I guess the price is going to rise then. Yeah. It's going to sucks.
So did you study for data science interview?
I spent a week learning SQL just like I did.
I think w three schools, I just picked it up super quickly.
Also learned a lot from brilliant.org. It's B R I.
They're not sponsored. It's not, we're not going to give them free sponsorships.
Oh, sorry. My bad. Um, to get a data science interview,
you need CQL and then you need like either R or Python and honestly that's about
it. Like when I interviewed for, um, analytics positions, like on the third end,
as the interviewer,
I kept on seeing resumes that were just like packed with every programming
language possible. And like I usually trash them cause like,
well the reality is that like all these people have the exact same resume.
Like it's literally template ID. Um,
and not like not the exact same word for word, but like objectively the same.
And then when I see a hundred of those,
I don't know which of the a hundred to pick. So I don't pick any of them. Uh,
the reason being like,
I look for people who have some distinct interest in the field and that gives me
a better signal.
Like there's a reason they're applying to this job instead of just spamming
their resume out to everywhere. Um.
Sounds a little bit like dating. It does sound a little bit like date cause uh,
you know, my profile is just generic so that I can apply it to most people.
Do you have a canned pickup line? No, I don't actually. I just say, Hey.
You say, Hey and that works. No.
Yeah.
Okay. I mean, that's the thing,
like if there are girls that I don't really care about, then I say, Hey,
because if they say, Hey back and they talked to me, they must really like me.
So I'd be down if someone's re like really into me. Right.
But if it's someone that I think like, Oh my God, she's so hot. Or like, Oh,
she's so interesting. Then I'll take more, like, I'll take the time to like,
look at a profile, try to think of a funny line and then do it.
How many responses do you get when you say, Hey.
No one out of 10 is.
Yeah. Oh yeah. Right when I attend, that's actually pretty.
Good. That's actually not bad. I.
Mean, I don't get along matches either. Right. So yeah.
You're saying that as if you have 10 matches, dude, you know.
This is an incomplete sample, small numbers,
half a response on the fly matches. So.
What did you learn about dating when you worked at Tinder.
So much? Um,
I'm going to try not talking about the math part first. Cause like,
I think there's a lot of cool math and there's a lot of like optimization,
but like what I learned more about was kind of the mindset of dating. Um,
and by that, I mean,
like you can really go into dating with two different mindsets. Well,
first off you could just not date.
And I know a lot of people that do that and like they're happy doing that,
but they also want to get married and they just don't know when that's going to
switch that little switch, going to flip and they're going to be like, wait,
I need to start dating. So a lot people just kind of push it off.
That's one like failed mindset. But the one that,
that a lot of people have is that like the first dates and interview and that
like, you're trying to gauge them. You're trying to be impressed by them.
And you're also trying to impress them and it makes it really stressful.
And I was guilty of this when I started dating too, where I was like, Oh God,
I have to be like on my best form. I got to put on my nicest shirt.
I got to like, you know, gel up my hair and all that kind of stuff. I mean,
what y'all hair, it looks really bad by the way.
But I eventually realized that like dating is about the process.
Like the process itself is the part that's meant to be enjoyable.
Just meeting people, doing things that you want to do. Anyway,
I started going on like fun dates instead of just getting dinner every single
time. So like, I'd started doing like mini golf or even like laser tag,
like these childish, but like fun dates, like hiking, all that kind of stuff,
just so that you enjoy the experience and like having someone there with you
makes it that much better. It's no large contingent on that person.
One of the things I learned at Tinder from like all of the research and
interviews I did is that like the people who go into that mindset are just so
much happier with the process. And they're a lot more successful, too.
Interesting.
Like I think fundamentally I'm kind of the same.
Like I just want to have fun and stuff like that. You know,
I'm not trying to impress them. It's not an interview,
but the process is totally different versus you.
So you're trying to have like a fun day, you know,
like laser tag and stuff like that. I always do the same day.
What's your date? Well, Oh. What's your move. I don't know if I can say this.
Uh, because ah, it. Okay. Oh my God. So everyone on my,
on my move because it's, it is the shoe. So I,
I bring them to the unnamed company. Okay. Where we work.
So I bring them there. Everyone says like, that's a balance thing. It's like,
it's not a good day or whatever. But for me it's because I want a low risk date.
Right. Because I don't even know if I'm gonna like you or not.
So why am I going to invest so much time and money into you?
And then because I bring them to campus it's free. Right.
Was she nervous about like coworkers seeing you like going on like a random date
and then like the cafeteria though?
No, I don't care what you like. Like, I mean, isn't it cool for me? I'm like,
Oh yeah.
The date I'm always like so paranoid that like people will start like whispering
and muttering about or whatever.
Like one of my nightmares is I run into a coworker while I'm on a date or
something. Yeah.
Yeah. Because I want them to talk about it. I want them to be like, Oh wow.
Joel was on the day. Yay. Kind of thing. But anyways, so the thing is,
even before I went to unnamed large company,
my dates would be always the same as in like, yeah.
It's dinner at the same place, dessert at the same place. Like it's,
it's like rehearse kind of.
Do you have rehearsed conversations too? Okay.
Rehearse conversations. No, but rehearse topics. Yes. Cause, cause they always,
it naturally into those topics. Right. But, but the thing is,
I'm not trying to like show that I'm really cool or it's like an interview or I
want to get to know them. Honestly. I, I,
I don't want to try to get to know them.
I just try. I'm not surprised by that.
In the, in a good way. Cause, cause I think, okay.
Honestly I think my second date ratios are pretty, is pretty good.
And because like I just try to entertain them for the first day. I, you know,
like my best jokes or whatever, I'm just have fun with them.
So I kind of want to break the ice as soon as possible.
And that's how I do it and yeah,
I learned nothing about them and they usually learn nothing about me either,
but we just talk about really random stuff. That's funny or it's fun.
I think the reason why it goes to the second day so often is because one
for once they don't feel like that awkward small talk or trying to force
yourself to learn about the other person because we didn't learn about each
other. You know, it was purely just fun. Right? Well,
that's how I enjoy my first days, at least.
And this is one of the things that, I mean I learned is that, you know,
the first date, you, you check off the boxes for the other person somewhat.
So like you don't necessarily ask them about their deepest personal secrets,
but like you find out if they're compatible religion, you ask about politics,
these things that are actually considered taboo,
like ensuring that compatibility like saves you a lot of time,
especially like in the Bay. Um, like word politics is such a big deal here.
If I'm dating a girl and like, um,
she's not cool with the fact that I'm libertarian and not liberal,
which a lot of girls here, like, aren't like, you know, I'm not,
I'm not crazy about it, but like if she's crazy about it and ends right there,
um, lot of people will assume that getting to the second date is like a positive
step.
I think a lot of times avoiding the second date can be a positive step in that.
Like you're getting that signal fast enough that like you figure out whether or
not you actually have interest in this person. And that's not me rationalizing.
Cause I never go on second. But like I, I think, you know,
in general, whenever I've gone past the second date,
it's been with someone I've actually been very compatible with.
And I feel like that's been more valuable to me than kind of wasting my time on
second and third dates with people I'm not actually interested.
I think that makes a lot of sense because yeah, no, most of the times,
like even if I go to seven days, third dates,
I don't really like the girl that much. Right. And I think that's a problem.
Cause I wasn't optimizing for like, Oh, finding someone that's compatible.
It was me just maybe just like an ego thing, try and be like, Oh yeah, yeah. I,
I got to the second day kind of a thing and it was a lot less about us,
but more about me kind of a thing.
It's like really easy to say, like check points.
Like even everyone does this on Tinder too. Right?
You compare how many matches you have with other people. Um,
part of it's because the process is gamified.
And so like it's really easy to tie things to it and calculate exactly how
you're doing and track all that. It's addictive. It gets people to keep on.
Yeah.
Yeah. For a potential girlfriend, there are certain check boxes. Right.
But these check boxes don't really mean anything.
Once I start talking to them and I just really enjoy myself with them,
I always end up in the stage where it's like, Oh, I really enjoy this person,
but she doesn't have these certain check boxes. You know, it's,
it's a little bit shallow before a girlfriend or at least like, or like a wife,
you know, I want her to make at least decent money, uh, college educated,
stuff like that.
But sometimes I meet girls who are like not college educated even, or even, um,
they do something that I really don't care about,
but I have a lot of fun with them.
So I continue to like hang out with them, but it always has to end.
Hanging out. Yeah. I go on dates.
You with them a lot. Right? Yeah. Cause I do enjoy their company,
but then once it comes to like something more serious, it's like,
Oh it has to end. And I feel like I've wasted a lot of my time because of them.
I like that whole increased wellness thing or like crying yourself,
wiping away the tears with your mom.
So much casual sex people just look at me,
it's take a piece of meat.
Because you know, dating is kind of like a funnel, right?
Like you have to get matched first and then you have to get whatever dah, dah,
how do you optimize the top of the funnel, which is through dating apps. Yeah.
99% Of your profiles, your photos. Right. Everyone says that bio matters.
Bio doesn't matter. Um, I'm going to call out one of my favorite books,
which is data Clarism. Um, it's written by Christian rudder.
He's the former CEO of OkCupid, really smart guy, really fun guy.
And he did a lot of analytics.
So he'd actually eventually stepped down as CEO to go 50% CEO and then 50% just
writing the blog and doing analytics at okay, cute.
Because that's what he really loved doing.
And one of his posts is about how they try to have OkCupid,
like users rate other users based on their looks and based on their personality.
If you had really good books, you also got rated really high on personality.
Even if you had a blank bio.
They showed this one girl who was like.
It's like a black and white model photo of her with like a log or something
here. You can, you can just edit it in. And right here, something like that,
her like average personality radios,
like a 4.5 out of five or something just because she was that hot.
It really is your photos that matter. Um,
I don't think many people are naturally ugly.
I think a lot of people just don't feel comfortable with having photos taken of
them like myself, a hundred percent included there. So when I started at Tinder,
I had a lot of like blurry photos, bad lighting, you know, group photos,
that kind of stuff. Cause I don't like being in front of a camera.
I'm one of those people where like my natural reaction to seeing a cameras,
to do like a stupid face kind of thing. It's just, I did that. Always,
even as a kid, I fixed a lot of that. So like I, I learned how to smile.
Normally I kind of upgraded my photos a bit to be more about okay.
And going to use like the timer or you could take selfies with a good camera.
I have friends. So friends are, Oh yeah.
No, I don't think any of my photos or selfies. God, I hope they aren't.
You know my profile picture like that.
Yeah. Actually most of them that's, that's a timer, right? Yeah.
It's so what I mean, it is a selfie as an I took it, but yeah. It's the timer.
How many takes did you have to do for that one? I don't know, like 20 something,
30 something I don't, you are dedicated. And I do a lot of faces to like.
They all look bad.
The one that's like, okay.
And then when I put on like Facebook people secretly tell me like, Oh,
by the way, it's not a good photo, man. It's like, you don't know,
what's a good photo of yourself. Not always. Right.
There's one like secret trick that does actually work,
which is including dogs in your profile.
And like it's one of those stereotypical things where people think it doesn't
matter that much, but it boosts your right swipe rate by like a huge margin.
Just having a dog in your profile. Even if it's not your dog.
I did have my dog in my photos either.
Like I have a dog and I had a cuter dog in my photos instead.
Yo my dogs.
Or a puppy. So I had to find this other puppy and put him in. That would be, um,
I don't love you. Absolutely love my dog. I'm sorry. Is that okay?
Cool. Very good boy. So I guess for the remainder of the time,
we'll just talk about like you as a person. Cause uh, you know,
people want to get to know you. I think at least like the people on discord.
No, there we go. You got like five people who are interested.
We're gonna get 10 views on this bad boy. So what do you do for fun?
So I was a competitive gamer in college. Oh. Um, legal legends.
I have no idea.
Yeah. Never told you about this.
Which I played at. Um, I've been playing since season one.
I got up to like high master.
It was really close to challenge or back in the day. Um,
so I used to play a lot, just end up on like pro streams just to get recognized.
That was like a big motivator for me.
I still play now if I'm not feeling as good,
but like just the fact that people knew my name was like so satisfying to me.
Even if they didn't think I was a good player for my rating.
I was known for being one of the worst players. That was your rating. AP Sona.
Oh I know he's soda. Why did I play soda?
Yeah. I, you know me too. Holy.
It's fun. It was a time sink. Um, so I, I still play that.
I do bar trivia bar. Oh yeah. I was a Quizbowl nerd in height.
Wait,
so is it trivia for anything or is it just shows or it's a lot of pop culture,
a lot of pop culture.
Um, I'm a sports buff mostly. So like I do,
I do fantasy football and I watch a lot of hockey.
I'll go to maybe like five or six sharks games a year,
beginning into couple of weird things recently. I've been getting not weird,
but like weird for me beginning into meditation.
Oh, that's good. That's good. I tried getting into it. I was okay for a while,
but then I suddenly stopped and then I never came back.
I think I should try to come back to it, but why do you like that?
I, I recognized I was like getting stressed just,
and so like it was one of those things where I was like, I need to control this.
They use Headspace. Yeah. I use space. That's AIG now.
Um, what level are you bro? I mean,
I I've only been doing it now for like a few weeks. Yeah.
Amateur hour here. Um, but it's been helping so far.
I think it's important to get that. Like I'm going to make a bold statement.
I don't know if it's true.
I think anxiety and depression are pretty common in the Bay area due to the
amount of stress that work puts on you here.
Like I definitely felt more stressed here than I did when I was living out in
Texas. And I think that's true for like a lot of other people. Okay.
So that's been one thing. The other one that I'm starting to learn is Mandarin.
Um, so I can hit on Chinese coworkers. Um,
I'm starting to learn like basic sentences, understand the tones,
that kind of stuff. Cool. It's one of those things where like,
I feel like it's actually useful to know here given that like so many of my
coworkers are like native Mandarin speakers.
Whenever I've learned a language in the past,
you hit that point where you need to start like speaking it with people and then
like, I didn't have anyone to speak anything with, um, here.
I don't think that's gonna be a problem. Yeah.
So lots of coworkers. Yeah. Cool. All right. Well that's about it.
Thank you so much for the interview. Thank you. Thank you about dating.
Um, you know,
hopefully a lot of my viewers are gonna get some tips and tricks and then they
won't watch my videos anymore because they have something better to do.
If you hit up the discs.
I will give out some profile critiques to y'all, you know? Yeah.
It takes me like 30 seconds both to critique a profile and also in bed. So
it'll be quick.
All right. Cool. Cool. So, yeah. So before ending,
I just want to say that this video is sponsored by express VPN and protect our
private data better than Cameron protects his virginity with express VPN.
I use express VPN when shopping or working on sensitive stuff abroad or in
public cafes in those cafes, their networks are unsecured.
So it leaves user at great risk. For example,
a man in middle attack can occur when someone intercepts her data requests.
So it allows them to eavesdrop and exploit real-time transactions and
conversations,
allowing them to steal your personal information express VPN lets you use the
internet without being tracked, keeping your emails,
downloads and search histories. Private.
Every time you use the internet without express VPN,
you're putting your sensitive data at risk express VPN costs less than
$7 a month and run seamlessly in the background of your computer phone or
tablet.
Take back your internet privacy today and see how you can get three months free
by going to express vpn.com/joma.
That is E X,
P R E S S V P n.com/j O M
a for three months free with a one-year package. So yeah.
Visit express vpn.com/joma to learn more.